in this video we are going to talk about
the coagulation cascade before beginning
make sure you have seen the first part
of the video which explains the clotting
factors in detail I will leave a link to
that video on the screen right now
be sure to watch that video for a better
understanding of this topic let's first
have an overview regarding what happens
in the copulation cascade so we have a
intrinsic pathway and then we have an
extrinsic pathway they both eventually
lead to the formation of prothrombin
activator which is actually the
activated factor 10 once prothrombin
activator is activated it in the
presence of calcium ions it converts
prothrombin to thrombin and when
sufficient quantity of thrombin is
formed in the blood it leads to the
conversion of fibrinogen into fibrin but
initially these fibrin are just monomers
and they cannot form a stable plot so in
the presence of calcium ions the fibrin
stabilizing factor which is actually the
factor number 13 it acts on them and
converts them into fibrin polymers by
formation of covalent bonds in the
fibrin monomers and eventually they lead
to the formation of a clot by attracting
lots of platelets lots of phospholipids
and other materials which add hers on
them and form the stable clot which
plugs the bleeding site and leads to
hemostasis let's first talk about the
extrinsic pathway so the extrinsic
pathway begins with any factor which
causes tissue trauma
now this drama can be trauma to the
vascular wall itself or it can also be a
trauma to the extra vascular tissue and
this causes the release of the tissue
factor also known as tissue
thromboplastin now this tissue factor
causes the conversion of factor number 7
to activated factor number 7 and then
the tissue factor combines with the
activity factor 7 in the presence of
calcium ions and causes the conversion
of factor number 10 to activated factor
number 10 and then the factor number 10
which is activated in the presence of
calcium ions and
number five forms the prothrombin
activator and arrests events are the
same that is the program in activator
causes the conversion of prothrombin to
thrombin now let's talk about the
intrinsic pathway intrinsic pathway
begins with any factor which causes
trauma to the blood cells directly or
causes the exposure of the blood cells
to collagen
this causes activation of factor number
12 so when the factor number 12 is
activated it acts upon the factor number
11 and causes its activation that is 11a
and this 11 a factor acts upon the
factor number 9 and forms the factor
number 9 a and these reactions require
some cofactors such as the high
molecular weight Keynesians and calcium
ions and undi
9 which is activated in the presence of
factor number 8a which is derived from
fact number 8 it combines with calcium
ions and causes the activation of fact
number 10 and then the events are almost
same as that of the extrinsic pathway
that is combination of the activated
factor 10 to calcium ions and factor 5
and formation of a prothrombin activator
and the Protomen activator subsequently
acting on the prothrombin and formation
of thrombin so to summarize what happens
in the coagulation cascade we have the
intrinsic pathway and the extrinsic
pathway they both ultimately lead to the
formation of a prothrombin activator
that is activated factor 10 and this
causes the formation of thrombin from
prothrombin and the thrombin acts on
fibrin ocean to form fibrin monomers but
these monomers are not stable and they
cannot form a clot so the fibrin
stabilizing factor which is the factor
number 13 it acts upon the fibrin
monomers and forms a lot of covalent
bonds between the fibrin monomers and
this leads to the formation of a fibrin
mesh and this mesh attracts platelets
phospholipids and forms a stable blood
clot which causes hemostasis so this was
pretty much all about the coagulation
cascade I hope you find this video
informative make sure to hit the like
button below and also subscribe to our
channel we have tons of upcoming videos
on hematology gastroenterology and many
other topics so make sure to hit the
subscribe button to have a regular
update about those videos also make sure
to like us on Facebook we discuss lots
of tips tricks and lots of mnemonics
regarding studies anyways thank you for
watching this video